when I was watching this film I remember
reading the article years ago about John
Cage talking about finding this
container they he walked into that
apparently had no sound in it and when
he was in there this sand became
incredibly noisy and he realized it was
his heartbeat and watching this film I
just thought that this isn't just a film
that doesn't have much sound in it
there's layers and various levels of
sand and Eric they the I've read an
interview with you and you said every
little sand is actually a big sound in
now that's right and you know the the
device that you're talking about that
John Cage mentioned it's called an
anechoic chamber and these are the
quietest places on earth that you can go
into because they're completely
sonically isolated from the outside
world not just with sound actually but
with radio frequencies and they're often
cased with lead even electromagnetic
waves don't even come in and you can
walk into these things and what's
fascinating is half you know the first
thing that happens is you lose your
balance because there's no even the
sounds you're making are not reflecting
back at you so and people forget that we
use our ears to orient ourselves and
balance
so um you're asked to sit down in an
anechoic chamber the second thing that
happens is that after a few minutes your
ears kind of start to open up and you
start to hear your own body and that's
the circulatory system the blood
coursing through your veins the cavity
of your chest breathing and these small
sounds become really big sounds and that
was kind of the effect we were going for
with a quiet place was to create a track
that opened the audience's ears up and
and eventually put them into the shoes
of these characters and and create kind
of a sound experience and that's that's
what our director John Krasinski wanted
to happen and we we knew it would be a
Hugh
challenged to try to achieve that it's
it's interesting you bring up the John
Cage reference because when we started
working on the film you know we the
first thing we did is we saw the first
assembly basically of the movie and I
think what we both Eric and I connected
to most strongly was the love between
these characters that you that you feel
and we thought how can we lean into this
the intimacy that you feel between these
characters in this tangible love between
these these members of these of this
family that are so desperately trying to
survive and so the first thing we we
started doing was stripping out music
because there was basically wall to wall
tent music and once we did that we
realized how can we get closer to these
characters and with the daughter Regan's
character she's she's deaf in the movie
and she's played by an actress who's
deaf in real life Millicent Simmons and
John described to us how Millie onset
became kind of the spirit guide for that
for the actors
she taught all the actors American Sign
Language which they use in the movie and
so when we started working with the
sound design on the film we were
thinking how we want to get closer to
these characters we want to feel what
they're feeling and with Millie's
character we were like okay she's deaf
this is a world where sound is
everything if you make too much sound
you will get killed and so in a way
Millie became our spirit guide for sort
of unlocking the sound design to the
film because
we had a description from John of
Millie's experience of which which how
she experiences the world when her
cochlear implant is turned on and he and
she described it as being sort of a low
Rumble almost you know hearing as touch
in a way and Eric and I immediately
related it to our own experiences being
in anechoic chambers where as eric has
described what you really hear once your
ears
open up after five or ten minutes is the
sound of you know your own body your
heart faintly pumping in the background
your nervous system sort of buzzing away
and so we based the sound design on
those experiences for for these moments
in the film when millie when we're in
Millie's sonic perspective and she has
her cochlear implant turned on and then
as you know there's three moments in the
film where she actually turns turns it
off and these are the three moments in
the film where we go to a complete
silence Digital zero which you know if
you think about it when do any of us in
in today's world ever have the chance to
experience total and complete silence so
the first time we tried that in our
editing room we were both like you know
it literally took our breath away
because it's such an unusual experience
to have and also in the context of the
movie it immediately connected us in
such a deep and powerful way with her
experience and her bull nur ability that
it was it became very moving and it in a
way sort of unlocked all the potential
in the in the story and in these
characters experience
[Music]
[Music]
you